all right Justin and Dre yes yes sir
Justin and Dre where you guys from
originally I'm from North Carolina I
grew up in Victorville
California and you guys have been uh
living in your car for a while right
yeah yes sir unfortunately how's how'd
you get into that situation um due to
the circumstances upon me using Med
fetamines and causing us to be evicted
from our serber
living you guys met how long ago
approximately 5 months ago mhm July
23rd and and Dre you're using I'm an
alcoholic
alcoholic I like fetl methan fetamines
but I'll do any drug and when I'm in a
blackout I'll do any
drug and you guys have been playing
around with drugs since what age I've
started at the age of
12 um I would say I was like 15 the
first time I tried um weed I didn't get
into heavy drugs until I was 25 before
it was just um marijuana and um alcohol
and then when I turned 25 I started
using methamphetamines for work and then
it gradually increased to Fentanyl and
then I just became a full-blown addict
using anything and everything have you
tried to quit yes multiple times fentel
is tough I it is take it
yes what was your uh childhood like
growing up in North Carolina Justin my
childhood was very lavish I loved it it
was very lavish um I was spoiled my
grandfather buils Yachts for a living um
my dad's family we did a whole bunch of
outdoor experiences and events and I was
very I was very
um I had structure stability and then
when I turned 14 I became a delinquent
and that's when I started using drugs
and alcohol and partying and U I kind of
pushed away my family so well why do you
think that that
happen that uh that that's I don't know
I started using drugs and alcohol just
to to fit in and then my grandparents
didn't like it and kind of shunn me away
kind of cut me off and I just started
going harder do you do you talk with
your family now yes you do my my mother
and my father that's it and my
daughters how many kids you have I have
two children I have one Abigail she's
eight and I have one levinia she's 14
and there with the mom yes
sir and Dre you started early as well um
I started smoking weed I think I tried
it first time when I was like 15 and
when I was 15 and a half I think I tried
alcohol for the first time but it I
didn't go really
hard until I got it was just here and
there I I have five kids so I got
married marri at a young age and
immediately had kids and um when my my
ex-husband broke my
nose I found out he had been doing drugs
and um I had to you know hold it
together to uh take care of my kids and
to support my family so I didn't really
become a hardcore alcoholic until after
I had my fifth child in
2016 I was in a very uh volatile Rel
relationship my ex-fiance wouldn't um he
was very jealous and I wasn't allowed to
go outside um I couldn't take out the
trash I couldn't check the mail and um
so I just started drinking and I'd
always drank here and there throughout
the years but I had a lot of
responsibility so I was able to function
and manage my life but um after I had my
fifth child and I couldn't no longer
leave the house that's when I um
the abuse was so bad that I just would
drink and drink and drink I didn't want
to live anymore I didn't know how to get
out of my
situation what was your childhood
like
um I guess like I thought it was a
normal childhood um my parents were
married until I was like 14 and a half
15 my dad was uh very violent he would
hit my mom and he would beat the crap
out of my brother and me and um I was
very emotional and verbally and
physically and mentally
abusive you feel like your childhood's
kind of led the way I mean not yours
Justin but Dre do you feel like your
childhood kind of led the way to your
choice and partners and oh definitely I
um I I grew up not feeling very loved I
never felt like I was good enough and
um I I've just always had had really
really low
self-esteem what what brought you to La
I initially came to LA from North
Carolina for Recovery I got insurance
great Insurance um a detox facility flew
me out here I completed a 30-day detox
residential program and went to um a
subber living and continued treatment
Beyond there things got a little bit uh
stressful for me and I turned to the
only thing that I knew that made me
comfortable which was drugs so I left
the rehab and I went to the streets of
LA and started getting high that lasted
for a couple weeks two or three weeks
and then I just I couldn't do it anymore
he's uh it's a different world over here
at North Carolina streets are different
yeah very different yeah and uh but one
anic only knows one thing so but I just
had enough of it and so I got back into
detox and got back into treatment and
was doing good for a while met this lady
we're doing good we're doing great and
then I relapsed
again how long you guys been together
since July 23rd this year we met um and
in detox it was a detox facility but
kind of like a PHP program and how do
you guys feel I mean do you guys think
that being a couple helps you in terms
of like recovering getting clean and all
that or does it get in the way it helps
that to not be alone because when you're
all alone um it's a lot darker and when
you have someone there with you um it it
helps get through like the really hard
times
but it kind it kind of requires both you
guys to kind of get cleaned together
doesn't it yeah
absolutely um when he relapsed they
kicked us out of our sober living and
this was the end of
September I had to they kicked us out
and I was going to school full-time uh
Santa
Monica um we didn't have we didn't have
a car yet so we were like legit like
homeless on the streets um luckily I was
still getting disability so I was able
to have I had some money coming in every
two weeks and I was able to get us a
hotel room um I relapsed with him I was
under the impression that if I relapsed
with him then I could go we can go to
detox together and then um they would
we'd be able to go back to our sober
living but um that didn't turn out to be
the case because um after I decided to
relapse so that we can go together then
they would not accept us into deta Bo so
now it's like now we're both like on the
streets and both under under the
influence and it I think we spent about
a week uh living in hotels and uh trying
to get into a detox and um we did get
into a detox boom we went right in there
we left so much stuff at the hotel room
like cuz when we left the serber living
like when we were in the serber living
and she was getting disability we were
just enjoying life just doing us you
know going out going to the beach just
going walking just doing whatever going
shopping going hiking yeah just en
rolled to go back in school full time
sprucing up our room and stuff you know
so when we got kicked out here we are
with all this stuff like clothes and
furniture and you know and inwhere to
put it yeah so we went to a hotel room
you know and then moving from one hotel
to the next eventually this stuff just
kept decreasing and decreasing and when
it was time for us to actually when we
finally got into a detox it was like
we're going right now like not after we
get out to shower not like after we go
down and get something to eat we're
going right now oh the Uber's outside
only this will fit in the Uber well that
stuff screw it it's got to go you know
what I mean so we left so much stuff at
that hotel like clothes electronics and
just because we couldn't fit it in the
Uber to get to our detox you know but
you got to make sacrifices and now we've
gained all that stuff back that was that
was uh back in September we've done
gained all that stuff back we got a
storage unit now full of stuff where you
staying now in our car you're living in
your car yeah and the back window is
busted out and the back the back the
very very back window the rear windows
busted out and the driver passenger
windows busted out Jesus on Christmas we
were supposed to go to my uh family's
house and um we slept in the car
Christmas Eve and in the morning I got
up and started to get ready we still had
a bunch of Christmas presents we needed
to wrap and um I was rushing him um
nagging
nitpicking to hurry up cuz we got to W
these presents so we can go to my dad's
we got to beat at my dad's by 3 and he
got mad and uh
um started drive all crazy me um he hit
me and um I started crying your dad hit
you no I didn't oh you did he hit me
yeah and so um when he got out of the
car I locked um all the windows cuz I
was scared and um so he broke them he
just went to the neighbor's yard and he
grabbed a big ass Rock and threw it
through the back window and then when I
got out the car um I started crying and
then he went to throw it again in the
back the back windshields and now was
like the the side window behind the
driver's side and then the back
windshield so I asked the neighbor to
call the police and they did and um he
took off
running and um I ran after him I was
like this you're going to jail like
you just like this is all I have this is
all I have is this car like we slept
we're sleeping in the car and now we
don't even have window like so the cops
came and
um uh cuffed him and we're going to
arrest him and um I uh told him how he
uh socked me in the throat and um how he
he was hitting me and then he was on the
side and he was like like
just not talking but like mouthing the
words like please don't send me to jail
on Christmas please don't send me I
guess he's been in jail the last few
Christmases and so he hasn't had a
Christmas in a long time um I'm a very I
try to be very family oriented so I
never miss Christmas with my kids you
know and it's a kind of big thing with
our family and we like to get together
and make a big family dinner and you
know spend the whole day like just
enjoying each other's company it's
Christmas you know well um I to I when I
saw he was like crying and I was like
okay so I asked the officer I told him
okay I wasn't get to press charges he
told me his mom would um fix my windows
on Monday or the day after Christmas and
um the cop was like well if he's hitting
you you're going to have to retract
statement for us not to arrest him
because um we by law we have to arrest
him if uh this really happened and it
did really happen but I uh retracted my
statement so he wouldn't go to jail
thinking like things are going to um
we're going to fix the situation but uh
things only escalated and he was driving
around all crazy
and he hit me a few more times and um
he wouldn't let me leave the
vehicle and I was just crying and I just
started to like say the rosary CU my dad
always taught me that when you're scared
uh just pray say the rosary and God will
answer your prayers so that's what I did
we I eventually um we went and got some
alcohol and we started drinking and um I
think I've um I had I think some sakil
which is like my night Med they give me
so I just took my night meds he took
some night meds and we just passed out
then to the next
day and um the next day
I called in to work and um it was just
like trying to put things back together
and um so that we get through the day
try to make a plan okay how we need to
try to get into a detox we need to go
get the rest of our stuff that's at the
sober living so we can finish putting
the rest of the stuff in storage see a
doctor because we both been we both have
been off of our our mental health meds
for two weeks and that's that's a really
that's putting a strong toll on both of
us mentally mentally yeah is that why
maybe the physical abuse happened yes
there's no justification for the
physical abuse I me everything I'm to
not nying it I'm not going to lie about
it I'm not going to deny it and there's
there's no justification for it but
there is a reason for it and me not
being on medicated properly is part of
the reason we both severe suffer from
anxiety depression uh
ttsd yeah add and we've been taking
medication for that but since we got
kicked out of our our our serber living
we're we're no longer seeing a
doctor we're not getting our meds I
couldn't afford my meds they um I've
been off my meds probably I think about
a month now um when I they finally I saw
a psychiatrist through the program I was
um doing going doing my IOP through the
doctor called in my meds and um when I
went to pick up my meds it happened to
be be I don't know like over $100 and I
was broke we had to spent all our money
on Christmas so I was just been trying
to put off everything until um payday
which is today finally we get I get paid
today so I could pay the storage and
um maybe get some of the medications
that were called in for me not all of
them but maybe some of them but yeah
where are you working um I work at
Kohl's um I also had got a job at Iran
it's a health food right um I only
worked at iron for about 2 weeks and I
let the job go cuz I just got a better
job doing U where I'm going to work at
graveyard at a mental health
facility for um struggling teens with
mental health problems so you're
supporting both of you yes I was working
in a detox facility but I just got fired
from
there looking back at your life what
what do you guys wish you had done
differently you have
regrets um I wish that um when I was in
after I had my baby and
um
when Mr Machado was like being very
abusive towards me and um abusive
towards my kids I wish to God when the
police came that I would have uh told
them that what he was doing because I
the kids told the police and then I just
denied it cuz I was afraid I didn't want
him to go to jail
I was just scared if he goes to jail
when he gets out he's really going to
beat my ass you know what I mean like if
he's beating my ass right now cuz I took
the trash outside can you imagine he
goes to jail he's going to come back
he's going to be way more Furious you
know um Mr Machado is who um Eric
Machado he was my ex- fiance he's the
father of my fifth child you you refer
to him as Mr Machado well actually I
call him Mr Rogers because he used to be
my neighbor but but his it um his name
is Eric Eric Machado and you know like
um the abuse I endured through that
relationship I don't think anybody
should have to go through that kind of
stuff I just was too afraid to tell the
police but because I didn't make reports
he now is like the person that's
supposed to supervise my visitation with
my baby and um you know he ended up
hiring the same lawyer that divorced my
mom and dad the same lawyer that
divorced me and my ex-husband and
um because he makes a lot of money he
can afford a lawyer and so the judge is
always going to listen to
whatever whatever the lawyer says you
know what I mean I can't afford a lawyer
I um I didn't want him to go to jail but
the series he was being very abusive and
he was hitting me he he raped me till I
bled like he he did horrible things to
me really horrible things
and I just I I was just I was scared of
him I was terrified CU he always told me
if I leave I think he was going to kill
me and I was just terrified I didn't
I didn't know what to do I didn't want
to live anymore I just I would just
drink um I got out of that relationship
because my parents came and got me my
dad came with
um with my ex-mother-in-law and they
came and got me and the kids while he
was gone he left and they're like he's
going to be back within 30 minutes you
got to get in the car and I was like I
can't you know if I leave he's going to
kill me and I was just terrified I was
legit terrified and um
I They Carried me to the car and um I
never went back with him and uh he tried
to say that I was kidnapping the baby
but I was like I'm not we had no custody
order we were all living together in
that house and um when we did go to
court he did like an expar to say like
that I took the child from him and that
basically I kidnapped the baby and I was
like no you know I had called him and I
told him that I went to family's house I
wouldn't tell him and which family
member because I didn't want him to show
up cuz I was scared
um but I admitted to the judge you know
like yeah I do have a drinking problem
I've the last two years I've been in
this very abusive relationship that
doesn't mean that's not an excuse but uh
I didn't know how to cope with uh all
the abuse I was going through I didn't
know what to do I I didn't know how to
handle the situation I honestly didn't I
didn't know what to do and all I did was
drink and I I did believe I had a
problem and I did believe I needed to go
to rehab I had asked him like 6 months
prior to that whole those chain of
events I had asked him if I could go to
rehab and he was like no because he was
he didn't want no one to look at me he
was so so jealous that he didn't want no
one to look at me so I couldn't I I
couldn't go to a rehab where there might
be a male there you know what I mean
that's why that's how I lost my
privilege as going through the groceries
store is because some um the guy get
bagging the groceries I said Thank you
and I wasn't allowed to say please or
thank you if it was like a mail on the
receiving end so it's just like when I
tried when I told the judge on our exp
parte like hey this is how things have
been I do want to say yeah I am an
alcoholic yes I have been being a bad
mother um this is true I I I do need
help where are your kids um well three
of my children of the five are adults
now and um my two minors they're with um
their
father how how old are you guys I'm
42 30
okay and the psych meds that you're not
taking are for which what do you guys
have that you would normally be taking
the meds for anxiety
depression
BTSD Andre um I have major depressive
disorder I have uh generalized anxiety
disorder I have uh PTSD and I have
ADD and I've been on my psych meds for
about um I want to say about 3 years now
so I've been whenever I go off my
meds um my life falls
apart I just can't afford them you know
right now and you you've been through
rehabs before yes I have I've been I
entered rehab for the first time uh June
4th
2018 and and from there I ended up
getting I had 9 months and then I
relapsed off and on for about 6 months
and then I got another 6 months over and
then I relapsed and it's just been like
I'll get 9 months relapse for 2 days
I'll get 3 months relapse for a week and
it's like when I relapse like because
I've been trying to get sober for the
last few years I haven't had I've had
more sobriety time than I have um
drinking time so I have no tolerance to
alcohol I take uh one drink and it's
like all of a sudden it's like I need
that it's like it's like it's like the
air I breathe I I need to have it or I
my I can't breathe inside like my
anxiety gets so out of control that I
it's um very debilitating I can't
function with when my anxiety is like
that because I'm afraid I don't know
what I'm afraid of but I'm
terrified you
know what's your biggest fear now my
biggest
fear I don't know my kids not wanting to
talk to
me my family been upset with me because
I relapsed again you know I had 14
months when I relapsed this last uh may
had 14 months sober and I I relapsed off
and on for two weeks and then I went
back to treatment and then um we met in
treatment that treatment facility and
then for 90 days you know like we were
sober maybe a little over 90 days I
don't know up until I relaps at the end
of
September and um I have no control like
once once I take that first drink I
literally I I don't know it's like I
know that alcohol destroys my life I
know that it's taken everything from me
but it's like once I take that first
drink it's
like it's like I can't think straight
it's like it's all I can it's like
that's it that's the only thing I can
think of you know it's like even though
I know that it's going to destroy my
life further I can't help it and then
once I enter after I have two drinks I
go into a blackout so I don't even I
don't even realize what I'm doing
anymore because I'm not conscious I am
no longer coherent and I will stay in
that blackout until I run out of money
or I wake up in the hospital or I wake
up in jail for a drunken public yeah
I've heard it said you have an as an as
an addict you have an on switch but you
don't have an off switch yeah I've heard
that and Justin what would you say is
your biggest fear uh letting my children
down
[Music]
again what's been your lowest
point being here in California and being
in the
streets I can't I can't function
here you've had hard times on the
streets yes what kind of stuff have you
been through
homelessness
burglary violence
destruction you were telling me
something that happened in the carther
Park yeah um so I went to go Christmas
shopping um you can get decent INR
the par for cheap so I went get
Christmas shopping and I dropped my
money clip somebody seen it and I went
to go to the car to leave and as I was
backing up two people rushed the door
one on the driver one on the passenger
and there was one behind the car and
they held me at gunpoint they took
everything that I had it was like $320
in cash
uh brand new cell phon some K Christmas
presents uh my backpack with you know
varities of stuff in it and um even the
car
keys so not the car just the car keys
yeah so I went back and told her and got
her and then we got an Uber back to
where the car was and we sat there for a
while waiting for AAA to come with tow
truck we sat there for hours because the
triaa the first one pass us didn't even
see us in the parking lot he just kept
going on the road and then second one
that came in had a flatbed when he
needed the allaround wheel so the third
one when he came he was able to tow us
but it was only able to tow us for a
certain distance not as far as we needed
to go so then we had to call Triple A
back out there to make us a key so we
had to deal with all that in that one
period of time mind you I had just
walked seven miles home from work to my
sober living in the pouring rain yeah
because I had no way to get up with it
was this last Thursday when it was like
raining like like hardcore rain not like
a little bit not a sprinkle it would
drizzle down to a Sprinkle but then it'd
come back again hard pouring green and
then it would then it would drizzle down
but the whole away seven miles honestly
I expected 7 miles to feel a lot longer
than it did but I mean I got it took me
3 hours to walk the seven miles and by
the time I got to the house I was just I
it felt so broken I was just I didn't he
still wasn't home yet I didn't know he
had got robbed a gunpoint all I know is
he didn't pick me up from work and I'm
soaking wet
and I don't know where the car is I
don't know where he is um he had the our
only working cell phone um I've gone
through a numerous amount of cell phones
in the past few months every time he
gets mad he breaks the phone so um the
only working what phone we had was a
government phone that I had just got in
the mail like maybe the week prior or
maybe not even the week yeah maybe about
the week a seven days maybe prior um I
went to Riverside had it mailed to my
dad's house I picked it up and that was
the only working phone so there was no
way I could contact him or or he could
contact me because we don't have a
phone but yeah you
know it's just been a struggle you know
and I mean I'm I'm blessed to say at
least I still have two
jobs however I um would like to get a
hold of my like mental health meds you
know and um maybe go back go back to
treatment for another 30 days you know
and try to get a
try to get
things um altogether under control again
because I can get a job I'm a hard
worker I'm I'm a good worker that's not
the problem it's um it's once um I start
drinking it all goes down here from
there what what do you think most people
don't understand about drug
addiction no one wants to be an addict
it's not fun I um I don't enjoy it I
don't enjoy drinking at all anymore it's
not like I'm I'm drinking because I'm
like oh like this is going to make me
feel better no it's like my anxiety gets
so out of control that I can't breathe
inside that I feel like like I can't
live like I can't live I literally feel
like I'm losing my mind I can't function
and the minute I take that first drink
it's like all of a sudden I could
breathe again the thing is once I take
that first drink my entire thinking
completely like
changes and it's no longer like okay now
you can breathe what are we going to do
now it's like I want
more no one wants it I love my kids I
want to be there for my kids I was a
good mom for like 17 17 years my oldest
son is about to be 24 and you know like
my kids had a pretty decent childhood
for the most part I did everything I
could to um give them the best life that
I could give them and and I I they never
really wanted for anything you know what
I mean like they played Sports I did I
was a soccer mom I even Vol volunteered
coaching I don't know anything about
soccer but I was even a soccer coach for
a second there but you know it's like
you do what you got to do for your kids
you know you learn to play catch you you
learn to do those things but see that's
before I was like a severe that's before
I crossed the line of like being able to
stop
drinking and like be like okay I can't
drink I got to go to work tomorrow
before I could still be like oh I got to
stop cuz I got I have a job I got to go
to I got to take my kids to school in
the morning I got to make breakfast I
got to make dinner you know what I mean
like normal things it's like now that
I've crossed that line like once I have
any kind of alcohol or drug in me it's
like that's all I think about and it's
not that I don't love my kids it's not
that I don't want to be a mom to them
it's that I can't control
it it's like a form of medication for
your anxiety now
yeah it it helps with um with my my I
can't breathe inside feeling that's like
the the worst feeling I don't think
people understand how um bad anxiety how
that how bad that gets my with my
depression I could sleep my life away I
can lay in bed all day and just lay
there and sleep and it's crazy cuz it's
just like it doesn't get old it's okay
I'll lay there I won't I won't want to
shower I won't want to eat I won't care
and anybody knows me knows I like to get
ready put my makeup on put on some
eyelashes and I like to look I like to
get fixed up where I look nice and when
I'm once I start using I don't care
about any of
that I
don't did you ever imagine when you were
younger that that you might end up in
this situation one day no by no means
I'm growing up my parents or while they
were married they were very um strict
parents um
I'd never been around anybody that had
been in and out of jail or did drugs
anyone that did drugs or anything like
that I can honestly say uh growing up up
until my up until my parents got
divorced yes my dad was very violent but
I look back and I realized like he
didn't do it cuz he was trying to hurt
us I think I know my parents after being
a parent now I know my parents loved me
and they did what they did maybe out of
frustration cuz they were young parents
too and because that's maybe the that's
the way their parents were with them so
you know what I mean so it was like a
different generation my parents were
born in like 1960 so it was okay to
spank your kids and you
know beat the crap out of them that was
that was normal you
know always I still think that that was
normal you
know all right Justin and Dre I thank
you so much for sharing your stories I I
wish you a lot of luck I hope you guys
fig figure out a way off the streets off
out you know something better than a car
to live in yeah there is light at the
end of the tunnel we uh we're in touch
with you guys still have hope with Vicky
and Paul and I think we're going to go
do their detox program so so you're
going to a program yeah after we leave
here that's where we're going for
program oh that's great yeah and you
just need to notify um my two jobs so
that um I don't like to leave my team
hanging you know I'm a I like to be a
team player so I just want to notify
that my boss that I'm going to go to a m
facility for 30 days and try
to get my life back on in control you're
both you're both going yes we're going
together that's great yeah we're ready
to shower and you know properly
nutrition oursel and uh mentally see a
doctor and getting back back on our
medication yeah I mean the the
mental health the uh psych meds all that
I think is a big part of it also just
believing that you deserve a better life
is a big part of it
too
all right love to do a checkup with you
after you've been through that yeah yeah
of course be very interesting thank you
all are you guys thank you very much
thank you thank
you